[Music]
i'm not going to teach you how to use
debt
it's like someone calling me on the
radio and saying
how can i build my credit score
i'm not going to assist them in doing
that although i know how
to assist them in doing that but i don't
believe it's good for them
and so i'm going to say i can't help you
with that what i can help you with
is that here's the reasoning why you
don't need to build your credit score
because it's an indication you've been
borrowing money your whole stupid life
it's not an indication that you're good
with money a high credit score is not an
indication that you're wealthy
it's not an indication that you're smart
it's not an indication of anything
except you paid a lot of
interest to some stupid butt bank for
the last 15 years
this is the only way you get an 800
credit score and so i'm not going to
help you build your credit because i
don't think it's good
for you if you want to do that you're
going to do that on your own and
you know but here's the thing if you're
going to
if you want to be agnostic as a
counselor
you're going to be ineffective agnostic
to the principles
think about a basketball coach if you
don't care about winning
you're not going to be a good coach
right and so if your player comes and
says hey i see that you want to run this
offense but really i just want to jack
up three pointers all day
then i'm not going to be your coach
you're not going to be on my team that's
the only way you can do that right yeah
you cannot be agnostic to principals
when you're coaching
especially for short-term business gain
that will
fail in the end every time every time
yeah when uh when people want to by
agnostic i'm not talking about faith i'm
talking about you
you're you're not tied to the principle
as having it works
once you be i'm not agnostic to the
law of gravity right i believe it
i believe it's a law i've experienced
its effects correct
and if my three-year-old grandchild
wants to
do something that's going to put him at
risk i'm not going to go we'll try that
flying thing and see how it works
just jump your butt off a two-story
building and see how that works out for
you
i'm gonna stop him from doing it because
i'm because i love him and it's going to
hurt him
you know it's a law it's a principle and
i'm not agnostic
but the three-year-old grandchild in
their ignorance may be agnostic too they
don't give a rip about the law of
gravity
because they don't understand its
effects yet and so this is
you have to adhere to principles in
order to coach
and so when you're a financial coach
you've got to have your firm principles
this is the way i teach
how to be financially successful and if
it's not a fit for you that's fine
because listen if you want to leverage
if you want to buy nothing down real
estate and you want to leverage
and go up your eyeballs in debt and buy
everything in sight
and not think anything about debt and
the risk associated with it and you
don't think debt is bad
you should see my good friend robert
kiyosaki he can help you with that
robert and i are friends he's a great
guy he and i completely disagree on this
and he's not agnostic about it either by
the way he's he
firmly believes it's the best way to
build wealth and i firmly believe it's
not
and but we're still friends we don't
disrespect each other and
anything like that but you know if you
want to buy nothing down real estate you
don't need to call dave ramsey he's not
going to help you with it
you need to call robert he'll help you
with it and so i'm not a fit for
everyone
if you want to be a bitcoin billionaire
you don't need to call me
because i'm going to tell you bitcoin's
stupid don't do it and and
you know which i need to say that at
least once a day because it keeps the
internet really buzzing
i'm happy to say the more i say it the
better it goes so
the better the better the social media
people the bitcoin
coin wears it's my favorite thing to
stir up since the gold bugs
it will be when i start stirred up all
the gold people but anyway yeah i don't
believe in buying gold either there's
some
let's piss those guys off i don't
believe in buying whole life life
insurance let's piss those guys off
i don't believe in buying a car on debt
ever
under i'd ride a bicycle wait a minute
do you like buying time shares dude
i mean you know this is the thing so you
really really really you you got to make
that call jake
and uh that's why john was questioning
whether you believe it or not i believe
you do believe it
but i think you're just trying to be a
nice guy
and help everyone and yeah yeah it's a
great point you can't do that
you're not going to be a good fit for
everybody it's going to cost you some
business and you're going to need that
extra coaching client and you're not
going to get that money per hour that
you've got built in
because you stuck to your principles and
that's how you win long term
and they'll say that guy jake me and him
don't agree but he doesn't know who he
is
and he's honest he was honest with me he
was honest with me told me not to do it
and
i've uh this is who i'm gonna be this is
the plan i'm gonna follow
i'd love to take you there but if that's
not for you then so be it yeah that that
that's the thing
it's a good question it just takes me a
minute to unpack why do i believe why do
i think that because it's automatic for
me yeah
after all these years of doing this it's
just autopilot i don't even think about
it
well and and i'll tell you back in grad
school we had some class sessions
on how to appropriately
break up with a client say i'm not a
good fit for you and i'm sorry
but you know what there's a uh it is a
skill you gotta learn right
but there's this thing and it's not jake
but there's this thing in the culture
and jake we're partially reacting to
that that
we're supposed to be okay with everyone
and i'm not yeah because some of them
are dumb yeah
you know you just need to you need to do
it you know you need to go that's just
there's a right and there's a wrong yeah
there's a good and there's an evil
and it's you know there just is yeah
and this thing you got to be willing to
do that you got to be willing to do that
or you're going to be ineffective